le 1
à montréal dans le parc cab auprès de
l'ancien forum et du métro atwater à
l'ombre de tours à bureaux et
d'habitation cet ancien vespasiennes
abrite le café de la maison rang
[Musique]
je vais prendre la t100 ouachita tempo
depuis tu peux tu me salis vinaigre s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
le café de la maison ronde c'est plus
que du café c'est un projet concret qui
ait vraiment professionnellement les
personnes autochtones qui les aide aussi
dans leur chemin de guérison qui vise à
être à aller vers quelque chose qui va
les motiver mais d'une façon comprend
toujours en compte
dans ce parc déjà très fréquenté par les
autochtones on utilise la culture
culinaire pour créer des liens avec les
gens du quartier des personnes qui sont
marginalisés loin de marché d'emploi qui
sont défendues qui viennent travailler
au café mais auront dans un but de se
remettre de son marché du travail
un des participants et terrain il a 23
ans il écrit est originaire de l'alberta
son parcours l'a mené à montréal
aussi que youtube
[Musique]
et lorsqu'on lui demande le secret de sa
salade il nous dit tout simplement bravo
à
tous les participants non pas un mais
qui porte leur nom cependant c'est avec
leur collaboration que le menu du café
était la borie non mais nîmes on est
vraiment parti de l'avant tous mes
entretiens avec les participants
énormément fait que chacun a apporté un
peu ça touche non plus dit avoir
familial fait que tous ensemble on est
heureux pinpoint plus dans le coin de
nous des exemples voir mais on avait
plus un peu ce qu'on faisait quand suite
et les catcheurs est ce qu'on demande
c'est quoi ça témoin ce que n'a pas
gommé pas qu'aux versions paroisse
ce mec est insensé de la banique avec
une suite dedans on emile huchet dans la
funci avec un étranger week-end
[Musique]
la panique est très présente sur votre
menu exact c'est un peu qu'ils étaient
notamment présents à la tradition
autochtone fait qu ici le plat principal
mes tiroirs pimpé avec des aliments à
peu près durant les plusieurs personnes
qui viennent travailler au café souvent
ont vu leur leurs parents ou leurs
grands parents ou leurs
arrière-grands-parents cuisinella bannis
mais il n'avait jamais fait un même pack
la peau russie une expérience de un peu
reconnecter avec leur culture
6 la farine de l'eau un peu de sel un
peu de poudre a parlé de ce pain là pour
faire des sandwiches des tacos exact
[Musique]
j'aurais bien oui vous je te prendrais
un tacot autochtone bien c'est bon pour
compenser avec un pogo
on est d'accord vraiment autochtone qui
comme une tradition entre les paroles la
banique 10 steaks hachés zone et salades
tomates un peu trop massacre sûr mais si
c'est pas du style c'est un peu facile
[Musique]
eh
ben tu vois tu prends sa cote est
végétarien motivé quand même avoir des
saveurs francs une tonne de pois chiches
mais certains assaisonnements mais y'a
de la net de deere fait que c'est ce
qu'il faut aimer lane est donc une fois
que dont l'intérieur est faible du fait
que rabbani si la populaire il la forme
avec la salade tomate et ils en font la
salade de pois chiches qu'ailleurs un
petit peu de mayonnaise et voilà même le
café a une saveur autochtone ils
viennent mockasin dû au fait que même
avec qui on eu à payer une petite
recette pour se sont vraiment pour le
café avec une hôtesse pression c'est un
petit secret mon un coup de chaud s'il
attendu
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu me demande moi comme
consommateur quand j'arrive comme
attitude important au café me demandais
quand même être facile parce que c'est
un regret d'économie sociale ça peut
très bien être la personne qui listera
la caisse ou qui fait sa nourriture son
café ça soit son premier quart de
travail ou café mais auront donc pour
faire attention de ne faut pas être
pressé poupe entend profiter de soleil
profiter de la terrasse qu'on offre
les compagnies
tout cela
[Musique]